in the case
that after
Sor a person has inadvertently has some
food lodged in their teeth yes
and as a result of swallowing and the
normal processes of saliva around the
mouth the food then is goes down the
esophagus into the stomach okay they
embibe it they take it on does this
situation mean they have invalidated
their fast and furthermore just as a a
sort of addendum what's the situation
when a person swallows Flem or
mucus as far as if a person has some
food particles that have got stuck in
between the teeth maybe after suur and
the fast starts if there are some food
particles which are stuck between the
teeth and if the person doesn't realize
it
and then if he swallows it without
realizing then the file doesn't break
but if the food particles are big enough
which a person can feel it then he has
to sprad it
out and
unintentionally if that food particle
after feeling goes in inside his throat
then Allah will forgive you then the
fast one invalidated but if you can feel
it intentionally F follows then the fast
breaks unintentionally if F follows does
not break so if there's a particle which
is big enough which can be spat outside
he should spray outside and
furthermore if suppose the gums bleed
maybe after using the Sak or after
brushing the teeth while fasting so the
blood also should be spat out
unintentionally certain blood goes down
the throat into the stomach Allah will
forgive you but intentionally you should
not swallow any part as far as the
second part of the question is concerned
that is about mucus if it comes from the
head maybe the pan is the sinus or from
the nose or
flim which comes while killing the Thro
if it comes into the throat and goes
into the stomach without coming into the
mouth it is quite natural it happens
with many people the flame the mucus it
comes get stuck into the throat you
clear the throat it goes down into your
stomach it's perfectly fine it does not
invite the fat because that's a natural
process but if it comes into the mouth
it should be spat out if the mucus of
flim comes into your mouth you should SP
out unintentionally if it comes in the
mouth and then you swallow it Allah will
forgive you but intentionally it should
not be swalled